will smith spot it for the first time
since slapping comedian chris rock at
the oscars after he made a joke about
jada pinkett smith's shaved head
resurfacing in mumbai india of all
places
[Music]
the 53 year old was all smiles as he
posed for pictures with fans and waved
to those looking on from a distance
the oscar winner was greeted warmly as
he went on to enter a building
the purpose of his trip is unknown back
at the table this is gonna be an
exciting one meanwhile back home jada is
back at the red table her facebook talk
show returned for a new season last week
and while the first episode was about
janelle monae
jada in the show took a moment to
address the elephant in the room by
sharing a message prior to the start of
the episode it reads quote considering
all that has happened in the last few
weeks the smith family has been focusing
on deep healing some of the discoveries
around our healing will be shared at the
table when the time calls
until then the table will continue
offering itself to powerful inspiring
and healing testimonies like that of our
incredibly impressive first guest thanks
for joining us jada if we don't talk
about it
we're not going to get to the other side
the premier episode for season 5 was
filmed before the infamous oscars
incident which led to the academy
banning will from all official events
for 10 years
[Music]
the decision to ban will was made
following a meeting held by the academy
board of governors after which the
president and ceo of the academy of
motion picture arts and sciences wrote
an open letter which reads in part quote
the 94th oscars were meant to be a
celebration of the many individuals in
our community who did incredible work
this past year however those moments
were overshadowed by the unacceptable
and harmful behavior we saw mr smith
exhibit on stage the letter goes on to
apologize for quote not adequately
addressing the situation in the room and
adding that they quote fell short and
were quote unprepared for the
unprecedented in a statement to et the
53 year old king richard starr responded
to the ruling saying quote i accept and
respect the academy's decision
will's wife
really should have been given some
consideration izzy recently spoke with
nba legend kareem abdul-jabbar he
believes that jada's voice wasn't heard
after will's oscar slap
well i you know i just felt that uh
will's wife
really should have been given some
consideration as to you know how she
felt about it
and what she wanted to do about it i
mean they just ignored her
altogether and i i didn't uh
i don't think that made much sense you
know she's the one that would have been
offended if it was offensive